bring sausage roll I can tell you that
already sausage roll all right all right
five minutes to live don't I mad Bible
isn't Ryan Reynolds here and I'm gonna
be playing a little thing called snack
wars they called a class I worked on the
restaurant industry for years and I had
no idea because I worked in shitholes oh
I'm sorry I'm eating pancakes like my
kid I can tell you that already
sausage roll all right all right five
minutes to live donate my favorite I'm
sorry it says the gregg bossen troll
pretty good recently there was a heist
of maple syrup in the United States's so
someone stole like two million dollars
worth of maple syrup which is amazing to
me like of all things to steal that's
like the greatest Canadian caper movie
that could ever be made okay I wonder
what's in here
Oh coffee crisp and a Cadbury Creme Egg
I mean yes brings me back to being a
caddy and running from the law
I'm kidding what I love about doing
interviews with lad Bible is the
diabetes these are Canadian as well you
didn't get these in Canada when I was 10
years old I snorted these but the coffee
crisp is better so Canada wins this
round okay so what what is that I mean
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna eat this now oh
I don't know what it is this is I trust
you guys right okay
we need to expand our horizons that's
not gonna work
and then Turtles of course enter Turtles
I'm gonna go Turtles for the win here as
a you just gave me a can of peach
smells like something that should hold
like massive amounts of industrial
equipment together and this just tastes
like nothing like a turtle but delicious
nonetheless Oh
Jacobs original pipe tobacco this will
be delicious and cheesie's oh yeah man
this is right here this child to 101
right here close it cheesy
rise up okay I think Canada's gonna win
this round although I don't know what
this is oh that's got a kick to it I'm
gonna go I'm gonna go with these
probably because they're not radioactive
so twiglets win wait is that gonna be
crush oh wow you guys I improved that
tastes similar to what this would taste
like to me that would like I mean you
have to be of like legal drinking age to
have this I forget like how intense that
is I'm going and brewing this for the
win maybe you guys can put some special
effects up right now that does this one
one all right we got Fig Newtons yeah so
what those are fig rolls you call them
here mm-hmm yep Wow cherry blossom
or someone's most recent dump okay oh
that's gross because there's like a a
liquidy kind of oozing fake cherry treat
coming out of there no thanks
UK wins again god I feel I really feel
like I'm betraying my country here
this whole exercise is totally moot
because you didn't give us a protein
versus fish and chips or something so
shame on you laughs I will shame on you